Hey everyone, how is it going?
Today we're going to be talking about coding bootcamps,
And while we're on the topic of non traditional ways to get into software engineering
I want to say thank you to the Great Courses Plus for sponsoring today's video
Coding bootcamps are short and intensive programs to learn
Software engineering skills, with the ultimate goal of getting a job
They're a great accelerated way to get into software engineering
Without needing to go through a 4 year degree program at a university.
They vary in duration but typically are around 12 weeks long
and demand about 40 to 60 hours a week of work.
Coding bootcamps teach you all the essential things you need to know to become a software engineer.
They teach you important computer science foundations and the real appeal is that
They also teach you highly specialized skills to become a specific type of software engineer
Think of it like a trade school if you will
For instance, if you're aiming to become a web engineer, a coding bootcamp will teach you
Ruby on Rails, React and Javascript so you can get a job as web engineer
Most coding bootcamp are held in person and you'll be part of
A cohort with a bunch of other people who are aspiring to be software engineers
There will be instructors giving classes on important software engineering topics.
You'll add these projects to your portfolio which you can list at your resume and you can talk about in interviews.
Most programs will also help you with the job prep process like helping to refine your resume
Or giving you resources on how to ace a job interview
I think this is awesome because a lot of times, no one is actually formally teaching you how to do these things,
Even in college
And getting advice from people who really familiar with the
Job and interview process in the tech industry is really useful
Bootcamps can be highly selective so you usually go through
An application and interview process to get into the bootcamp that you want
Because the bootcamps are very rigorous and highly demanding
They'll check to see whether you have what it takes to complete the course
So hearing all this, you might be wondering, how much do they cost?
It depends from bootcamp to bootcamp and what city it's in
But some bootcamps take a percentage of your salary and other ones require an upfront cost
For instance, some bootcamps don't require payment until 3 months after you've gotten your first job
Meaning you don't have to pay anything until then, so it kind of works like a loan.
Other bootcamps will require an upfront cost
and they'll usually be at least a couple thousand US dollars
I think the largest concentration  bootcamps in the US are here in the Bay Area
Mostly notably ones like Hack Reactor, App Academy and Hackbright
I know they're popping up in other areas too, so if you know any in your area
Then post in the comments down below
I honestly think bootcamps are awesome
It enables people who didn't have a chance to study computer science previously
Or maybe those who have found new passion for software engineering
To become a software engineer quickly.
There are so many software engineering jobs available
And it's no secret that we need more people in tech.
And bootcamps make this whole thing a lot easier for everyone involved.
I think going to bootcamps is just as great a way to become a software engineer
as it is to have a degree in computer science.
There are bootcamps targeted to get those from under represented minorities
into sustainable careers in technology,
And I seriously think that's so cool!
One thing to note though, is that while bootcamps are a great fast track way to become a software engineer
It isn't a guaranteed or easy way to get a job
I've heard from friends who've been to bootcamps that the hardest thing about going to a bootcamp
Is not the bootcamp itself, but it's getting that first job.
Everyone applies to hundreds of companies and it can takes months to find that first job.
That part can be really difficult but I think that it gets easier after that first job
My friends all now have software engineering jobs,
and they're really happy because they get to do what they love.
I don't mean to be a downer about it, I think bootcamps are still a great way to get into software engineering
But I just wanted to let you know, regardless.
If you've been to a bootcamp before then please leave a comment down below with your experiences
So I hope you enjoyed this video and before we get to the shoutout
This video is brought to you by The Great Courses Plus
It's an educational video subscription service with top notch instructors from universities across the world
And experts from places like National Geographic and the Smithsonian
With the subscription, you'll get unlimited access to a vast variety of 9000 videos lectures
Where you can learn anything from science to photography,
to how to play chess, to world history!
They also have an app which I'm really excited about
where you can stream these lectures from your TV or smartphone through the Great Courses Plus app
Self teaching is honestly another great way to get into software engineering and honestly anything at all.
But I was watching their How To Program lecture and it brought me back
to my Intro to Computer Science class that I took as a freshman in college.
You can start your free trial by visiting TheGreatCoursesPlus.com/mayuko
Or by clicking on the link in the description box below
Alright so today's shoutout goes to Dominic Paul who made an ARKit solar system app by himself.
That is so cool! ARkit, for those of you who don't know is Apple's new augmented reality kit
Where you can make augmented reality apps.
Awesome Dominic! Really excited for you!
the link to his tweet is down below, so don't forget to use a hashtag #heymayuko
To tell me what you're proud to have accomplished and you might get a shoutout in my next video
That's it for today, I will see you next time, bye!
Y'know, this is also kinda like a blanket
And so in a pinch, it becomes a scarf-blanket!